avec jean-pierre colombiès et les
porte-parole de l'union nationale des
policiers d'indépendants bonsoir merci à
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
on l'a vu que cette journée s'est très
bien déroulé il n'y a pas eu de heurts
pas de débordement non plus une bonne
nouvelle pour les forces de l'ordre ont
soir oui c'est une bonne nouvelle dans
la mesure où il n'y a pas
d'affrontements il n'y a pas de blessés
de part et d'autre quelques côté que ce
soit maintenant il faut pas trop se
faire d'illusions et nous sommes à la
veille des fêtes de fin d'année il ya
peut-être une forme de trêve où je
dirais de d'assouplissement des volontés
de s'exprimer il faut espérer que ce
soit pas le calme avant la tempête tout
simplement il faut pas se tromper les
revendications sont toujours là la
colère elle est là elle est existante
elle et elle est sous jacente à un
climat très anxiogène très dur je crois
qu'il faut se garder de tout satisfecit
prématuré de quelques côté que ce soit
il ya un nouveau de la sécurité qui
s'annonce pour le mois de janvier
l'objectif c'est pour l'exécutif le
gouvernement de regagner la confiance
des forces de l'ordre on parle beaucoup
de défiance d'ailleurs entre les deux
parties ce que vous confirmez
et comment est-ce qu'on peut mesurer
cette défiance comment voulez vous que
l'on croit un énième une énième
rassemblement une énième discussion qui
ne repose pas sur quoi que ce soit de je
dirais de crédible les revendications
des syndicats de police et pas
simplement des syndicats et des
policiers de la base d'un bien au delà
quand on voit bien qu'une fois de plus
c'est bon vous est organisé pour calmer
le jeu il y a une base policière qui est
parfaite qui est très mécontente qui est
très remonté faux pas ne faut pas s'y
tromper et des policiers dans leur
ensemble ou bien conscience que ce
boulot est fait pour calmer le jeu pour
calmer des esprits mais pas grand monde
n'y croit il est quand même surprenant
on voit moins que quelques quelqu'un qui
cache quelque chose au président en mai
mais surprenant qu'on élit des ce2 de ce
nouveau alors même que des
revendications existe depuis des années
qu'on a édité un livre blanc
considérable enfin on a un sentiment
véritablement que c'est un ce sont des
faux semblants que c'est un nuage de
fumée pour dissimuler cacher et à deux
des revendications à une colère réel des
policiers de base à ne vraiment vraiment
pas s'y tromper personne ne croit
vraiment à ce beau mot une faute très
clair et pour revenir à à la semaine
passée qui c'est bon il n'y a pas eu
vraiment une violence taille de casse
lors de du 3e samedi une manifestation
en tout cas gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur il a beaucoup twitté il
twittait le nombre d'interpellations
il a tweeté 142 interpellations et
encadrement du cortège qui a permis donc
de protéger les commerçants ce chiffre
il est remis en cause parce que 142
interpellations ont la question qui se
pose c'est de savoir si elle est
vraiment des black blocks parmi ces
interpellés des profils radicaux ou bien
si c'était des manifestants votre avis
là-dessus
vous savez communiquer par voie de
tweets c'est la mode ccc la façon
actuelle aujourd'hui quand tous les
politiques de communiquer vis-à-vis de
l'opinion publique ou vis-à-vis de de la
police des manifestants morts face à
être sa vie des limites
les interpellations dont on a tant parlé
des bouches quasiment aucune
condamnation et pour cause c'est qu'on
n'est pas capable dans ce pays encore de
faire la différence entre des
interventions sur le terrain
et la rédaction de l'établissement de
procédures judiciaires qui tiennent tout
simplement la route on perd de vue dans
ce pays que le premier et dernier
interlocuteur des policiers ce sont les
magistrats
si vous leur proposez des
interpellations sans motif concret de
mise en garde à vue c'est un peut
déboucher que sur délibération et une
absence totale de condamnations
on ne peut pas inventer des délits qui
n'ont pas été commis et quand bien même
ils ont été commis il faut le prouver
tout simplement donc tout ça est à
relativiser
on a vu des interpellations
effectivement faut se poser la question
de savoir s'il était préventive est
justifié au-delà de ça tout est une
question de sémantique pardon et de
prise de parole qui repose qui ne repose
pas sur grand chose de concret il faut
le dire
la polémique qui enfle sur qui a été
interpellé des manifestants ou vient
réellement des profils voilà radicaux
vous savez un criminologue disait il a
tout à fait raison que lorsque le
ministère de l'intérieur communique sur
le nombre d'interpellations ou le nombre
d'interventions il transfère propos
température c'est exactement ça je
mentirais pas un mot de ce qu'il a de ce
que cette personne a dit ça n'enlève pas
si vous voulez
l'analyse qui devrait présupposés à tout
ça qui est la raison de la colère qui
est la raison de cette mobilisation
permanente à laquelle on assiste depuis
plusieurs années maintenant et face à
laquelle on ne pose que des forces de
l'ordre forces de l'anp que l'on
stigmatise dans leurs actions d'un côté
comme de l'autre et il faut sortir de sa
part quelques voix qu'il soit mais par
une voie politique c'est fondamental il
y à un dialogue social à avoir il faut
effectivement changé le changer de
braquet que ce soit vis-à-vis de
l'opinion publique ou de même vis-à-vis
des policiers et ça n'est pas
systématiquement en se contentant de se
satisfaire de nombre d'interpellations
plein samedi qu'on va sortir de cette
crise on n'a jamais vu ça je ne pense
pas que les plus anciens des
journalistes ou les politologues les
plus anciens et vu une crise aussi
longue s'installer dans un pays comme la
france
en gros on est un petit peu dans une
gestion plus sur les faits 2
lens policières les accusations de
racisme systémique au sein des forces de
l'ordre
votre avis là-dessus et comment
justement on lutte contre des
comportements qui sont a priori isolée
au sein des forces de l'ordre
vous vous apporter la réponse à votre
question
parler d'un racisme systémique
systématique enfin plombs ça comme on
veut et une là encore été vraiment c'est
la phraséologie c'est de la rhétorique
de francs sa dépose ça débouchera sur
rien c'est même dangereux dangereux de
faire croire que la police dans son
ensemble est une institution raciste
enfin suffit de regarder je suppose que
vous allez vous aussi dans la rue vous
voyez bien que les patrouilles de police
sont constituées de fonctionnaires de
toutes origines de toutes couleurs et on
veut on peut difficilement mettre sur le
dos de l'institution total des actes
individuels qui sont je le rappelle faut
quand même rappeler l'objet qui font
l'objet de sanctions je ne dis pas que
tout est parfait dans le meilleur des
mondes pas du tout mais ne jetons pas le
bébé avec l'eau du bain c'est dangereux
c'est très dangereux de se donner c'est
s'installer comme l'a fait le président
une ambiguïté sur ce sujet là la
passerelle qui l'a annoncée de
dénonciations sur l'igpn d'abord elle
existe déjà et ça laisse entendre que
healy a véritablement un problème de
fond au sein de la police nationale ce
qui est dangereux mais dangereux pas
simplement pour les policiers mais même
pour la démocratie
si vous déstabiliser une institution
comme la police la justice avec tous les
défauts qu'elle peut avoir je précise
vous mettez en danger l'équilibré même
de la démocratie tout simplement merci
beaucoup à vous jean pierre colombiès un
porte-parole de l'union nationale des
policiers d'indépendants merci